PROFESSOR: So now
that we understand
the types of droplets
that are emitted
by different types
of respiration,
and their evolution
in the environment
as a function of humidity
and other factors.
Let's talk about
the different ways
that transmission
can actually occur
between two individuals
of a respiratory pathogen.
So the first is
contact transmission
through so-called fomites.
These are residues of those
infectious droplets that
had been emitted by breathing,
which can build up on surfaces
such as tables, floors,
even on people's clothing,
on their hands,
from the breathing
of an infected person.
And then as a central
person touches
those surfaces and then
touches their eyes or touches
their nose.
And in various ways gets
the pathogen into their body.
So that is not likely to be the
dominant mode of transmission
for COVID-19, as the
evidence is building up
of other modes of transmission.
Nevertheless, it is
still recommended
to be disinfecting
and washing surfaces
to protect against this
potential mode of transmission.
Another mode of transmission is
through large ballistic drops.
So these are the
droplets we talked
about at the beginning,
some of which
are large enough to
sediment to the ground.
Others of which will
eventually settle,
but which can be
transferred by the momentum
of a cough, or a sneeze,
or some violent exhalatory
event to another person.
And that other
person can directly
breathe in those droplets.
So this is especially
important when dealing
with symptomatic individuals.
On the other hand,
for COVID-19, it's
well established that the
majority of transmissions
are, in fact, asymptomatic.
So people are not
coughing or sneezing,
and yet are still managing
to transmit this highly
infectious virus.
Which brings us then
to the third mode
of transmission, which is
through aerosol droplets.
These are the droplets
which do not settle quickly
on the timescale of occupancy
of the room, or a ventilation,
or other factors that
remove those droplets,
such as deactivation.
And those droplets are emitted
even in normal respiration/
normal breathing.
So just simply the puffs
of breathing, speaking--
put those aerosol
droplets in the air
and then they're
carried by air currents
in the room, which we will
analyze in greater detail later
in this course, and
essentially fill the room.
And as a first
approximation, those droplets
are spread throughout
the room, and is
a well mixed space of air.
And within that
context, there are still
two modes of transmission
we can talk about.
If people are not wearing
any masks or face covering,
then those puffs
of respiration can
be directly impinging upon
a susceptible person, who
then can breathe them in.
And those aerosols will be
at a higher concentration
than the background ambient
air of the well mixed room.
And we refer to that
as short-range aerosol
transmission.
And we will return to that in
the last part of the course.
But what we're going
to focus on first
is long-range
airborne transmission.
So these are the droplets
that end up in the air.
They become well mixed
throughout the space.
And anyone in the room,
even very far away,
can breathe those droplets
in and, over time,
can inhale an infectious
dose and become infected.
It's important to recognize
the role of face coverings,
especially in the context
of these respiratory
droplet transmission modes.
So whether it's a
mask or a face shield,
those facial coverings
can essentially
eliminate short-range
aerosol transmission.
Of course, they also completely
eliminate large drop emission
because the droplets
don't make it
through those ballistic
protections if you will.
And even the momentum generated
in the air from the breathing
is largely eliminated
by shields or masks.
On the other hand, these
small aerosol droplets
can pass through masks.
They certainly can pass
around face shields or even
plastic shields that you
see in various public spaces
these days.
And those droplets then are
quickly spread around the room
and we're left with the
airborne mode of transmission.
We will see later, there
is an important distinction
between a mask and
a shield, however.
While both of them blocked
the momentum of the fluid that
leads to puffs and respiratory
jets and plumes of transfer,
they do provide, in
the case of the mask,
additionally filtration,
which can actually
block many of the droplets--
not necessarily all,
but a significant fraction.
And that will be
an important aspect
of understanding
how to make spaces
safe from airborne transmission.